[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: It's an
honor to be here.
I wanted to begin by saying that
I've been interested in Cuba
for a long time.
We have an employee named
Brett Perlmutter, who's here,
who's really one of the
heroes of the company, who,
working with a team, has figured
out how we engage in Cuba.
And Google's position
is that we want
Cuba to be as successful
and connected as possible,
and we've done our part.
And I went to Cuba 2 and
1/2 years ago, and then more
recently, in December, so my
second visit, during which time
I met with
[INAUDIBLE] Leal who's
the historian of the country.
And I thought it would be
interesting to talk about Cuba
here with people
who are interested,
but also to honor your service
and commitment to your country.
So your background-- probably be
the most significant historian
in the country,
officially has the title
of the historian of Havana.
But if you've been
to Havana, you
know that it is the cultural
center of the country.
And I thought we should start
by asking you about Jose Marti
and why he's so important and
why you're here in New York.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Well,
first of all, I'd
like to thank you all
for welcoming here,
specifically to the headquarters
here in New York City, which,
by the way, is absolutely
beautiful and inspiring.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: I'm actually
in New York on, if you will,
what is a romantic
visit of sorts.
20 years ago, I
came to New York,
and I found myself
in Central Park.
And I found a beautiful
sculpture of Jose Marti.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: It was actually
put together or created
by an artist, an American
artist, who was a bit avant
garde in her creation,
because of the fact
that no other
sculpture of its type
had ever been seen of a poet,
historian, or statesman,
and it drew my attention.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Huntington,
who was the author,
studied the Italian
school of culture,
and she was able to take
the idea or personality
behind Marti and really
hone in on his personality
to create this work of art.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And, of course,
the type of technology
that she used in
creating this went
against every kind
of school of thought
at that time in the
creation of this monument.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And,
of course, an idea
came to mind at
that time, which was
to create a work of art that was
similar to the same sculpture
that I had seen in Central Park.
This was an idea
that, of course,
took two decades in the making.
And at the moment,
I'm actually very
close to coming to
fruition with that idea.
And, of course, the idea
of creating a copy of this
is also to create the same
type of sensitivity and genius
that this artist used in
honing in on the life of Marti
here in New York
City, who actually--
he lived 15 years here
in New York, more time
here than he did in Cuba.
And he experimented
with culture and all
of the American
know-how at that time.
So, of course,
now at this point,
I'm trying to see
what I can do to bring
that same type of appeal that
is found in this work of art
to the city of Havana that
saw Marti be born in Cuba.
SPEAKER: It's interesting
that in Cuba, there
are no statues of Fidel Castro.
And yet there is
a great reverence
for both Fidel and Jose Marti.
Why is it that there are
no effigies of Fidel,
but you're very
focused on Marti?
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: He was
completely against any sort
of cult of personality,
anything that
involved creating monuments
or statues or plazas
or institutions.
And he was completely
in tune with the idea
that Marti tried to leave
for the world, which
was to create a better world.
He then himself knew that
Marti believed in this,
and it was emblematic.
You would probably say that my
words are a bit contradictory
in what Fidel wanted, but in
essence, his passion will also
be part of this statue.
And it's also the
America that Marti
wanted to create, our America.
SPEAKER: So Google has
also helped with Marti
by building a virtual
reality demonstration
that we have showed off
for using our VR goggles.
And so I'd like to
understand a little bit more
about the history of Havana
and its preservation.
You were heavily
involved in making
Havana become a
UNESCO World site
and preventing its development.
Was that your idea?
Was that Fidel's idea?
How did it really work?
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: First
of all, I'd like
to thank Google for the
creation of the goggles,
where children are able to sort
of witness the history that's
been played out in Havana
for a very long time.
It's almost as if their feet
have been held to the fire,
so to speak, so that they can
actually witness everything
that's happening in real time.
And secondly, the restoration
of the Cuban Civic Center
for History, which has now
seen a Renaissance in what
is the new history that
will be created in Cuba.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Of
course, in keeping
with the tradition of
Spanish literature,
which is always to look back
into the past and sort of look
at everything romantically and
think that the past is always
better than the present
or even the future,
this sort of seems to
be the proper setting
for the narration of this film.
And of course, this
would be the best link
for the past to the future.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Of
course, this idea
was never really
understood, and I'd
like to hearken back to what I'd
like to call heroic times about
four decades ago, where I was
walking through the streets
and collecting all
sorts of information
to then be able to
recount all of this
and use this as a
point of departure
for this kind of
[INAUDIBLE] project.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Of
course, I then found
faithful workers, who
accompanied me on this task,
or adventure, if you will.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: My car
only had two wheels.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And of
course, at that time,
Alejo Carpentier, one
of the contributors
to the American letters, saw
this very thin, frail, young
boy walking down the streets
with a load of rocks.
And he asked, who is this boy?
And someone said,
someone who's actually
chasing an impossible dream.
And he said, he will
probably make it.
He will probably get very far
with that two-wheeled cart.
And it's actually
prophetic on his part
that he actually said that.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: At
that point, my work
actually became a sort of
Greek republic, if you will.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Since I
had to create everything
from its inception,
it's as though I
had to create both the bow
and arrow at that point.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Of
course, at that point,
Fidel came to me with a
delegation from Chile.
He came to old Havana,
and apparently, someone
had mentioned what
I was trying to do.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And
of course, he then
asked me, what is
it that you need?
This was after he had
finished his tour.
And I said, absolutely nothing.
And he said, if I asked you for
something, you won't come back.
He laughed, and he
laughed a lot, actually.
And then he left.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And
of course, instead
of being a subordinate
of his or someone
that was in need of something,
he actually became a benefactor
to this grand opus.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And that's how
the project actually came
to its inception as it is now.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: At that point,
many fortresses in the island,
on the island-- over
50 palaces, churches,
and all sorts of
plazas and arches--
began to be refurbished.
Radio and TV also lent
their help to this,
and it was all to sort of
create the infrastructure that
was necessary so that then
the information could also
be published.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: I gave up on using
my cell phone about a year ago.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: That means
if you need to find me,
you will find me.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Whoever
needs to seek me
out will definitely find me.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: I'm
actually free now.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: One of
the things that I
learned from you is that the
Spanish Cuban American history
was more complicated
than I thought.
And I learned from you
that the Cubans fought
with the Americans
against the British
and that Cuba was a
very important part
of the Spanish empire, and
much of their Caribbean work
was done from
Havana, which is why
Havana is such a rich place.
Tell us a little bit about all
of that part of the history.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: When the very first
lamp was filled with whale oil
on the streets of
Havana, the Puritans
hadn't actually reached the
United States yet, or America,
for that matter.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Only Spain
surrounded us at that point.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Even
so, even Florida was.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And, of course,
the North was unexplored.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Some
expeditionists had already
been to those areas.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: The
Mississippi River
was as legendary as was the
Amazon or the Magdalena River.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: When Havana was
taken by the British in 1762--
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: --after a siege
that took about two months--
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: --they
arrived at the capital,
and they set up what
was the British control
of the western
part of the island.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Among those young
officials that arrived in Cuba,
there was a young man,
a very tall young man
named George Washington.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Perhaps no
one knew at that time
that he would eventually
become the liberator-- excuse
me-- the founder of
the United States.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: That's where this
relationship actually was born.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: A very strong
economic relationship.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Between
Cuba and the colonies.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And,
of course, Spain
wanted to avenge this hostility
that it had towards Britain.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And when the
first cry of independence
took place in America,
Spain heard it.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And the
very first platform
of help for that event to take
place was the port of Havana.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: There
is still a stone that
reads, "The port of liberty."
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And, of
course, emissaries from Cuba
arrived at George Washington's
camp in Georgetown.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: He was
able to identify them,
because, of course,
they all belonged
to the same Masonic society.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Who
obviously believed
in the future, that believed in
the brotherhood or camaraderie
among human beings, that
believed in progress,
and believed in the
betterment of society.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: So, of
course, now that I've
had a chance to get this
out to the United States,
I've been in St. Augustine, I've
been in Pensacola, and Mobile.
I've seen some of the
cemeteries, and some of them
remind me of those
luminaries from Cuba.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And,
of course, when
Cuba began to fight for its
own independence in 1868--
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: --many
Americans, actually,
supported and sympathized
the Cuban struggle.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And many of them
also went to fight for Cuba.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And they, too,
are part of our history.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Those are the
most interpretive keys or--
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: So,
of course, we are
tied because of these things.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And
of course, Marti
was the supreme symbol
of those ideals.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And of
course, his last birthday
was the 28th of January,
1895, in the Delmonico
Cafe in New York.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And then after
that, he went back to Cuba.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: He was
only 42 years of age.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And as I
mentioned yesterday,
his life was as ephemeral
as that of a butterfly's.
SPEAKER: I have
one more question,
and then we'll go to
the audience questions.
Today, the links between Cuba
and America are being restored.
What is your hope
for the relations
between Cuba and Americans?
What would you like to see?
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: I'd like
to repeat something
that I mentioned before.
Cuba has always had,
has, and will always
have friends in
the United States.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Political battles
should never become vulgar.
They should only be
a battle of ideas.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: I cannot believe,
nor do I want to believe,
that we are doomed to have
this enmity among us forever.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And the most
flagrant manifestation of that
is the constant
blockade of Cuba.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Now that invisible
wall is finally crumbling.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: What we cannot
allow to see happen again is
that those gaps, again, are
filled with chains that we can
no longer open.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: We do not burn
North American flags in Cuba.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And
Americans are not stones.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Our
emigration from the country
has always been towards
the United States.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: I remember
there was a senator that
visited me several
years ago, actually, one
of the most important senators.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And of course,
after the conversation
was over, the blockade
was total at that point.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And
he said to me, what
is it that you would like for
me to bring you from the United
States on my next visit?
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And I
said to him, would you
be so generous as to be
able to accomplish that?
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And
I said, would you
please be able to bring me
an Oil Spice shaving cream?
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: The most
interesting thing
is that he actually made
[INAUDIBLE] to his promise.
He brought it for me.
He came back, and he brought it.
SPEAKER: I'm sure we can buy
it around the corner here.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: I
really do appreciate
the senator's noble gesture.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And I
believe that that
is what we need to aspire to.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Now that
the world is just
such a difficult place,
a complicated place.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: I think we
need to look for and strive
for that harmonious
connection between people.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Where faith
and social doctrines
do not separate us
from each other.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: At least
that's my vision.
SPEAKER: So with that,
do we have some questions
from the audience?
And please ask them in Spanish
if you're a Spanish speaker,
and we'll have our
translator translate.
Who'd like to start?
Yes?
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
SPEAKER: Sir, go ahead.
Please, please take
advantage of the situation
to ask any question.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: I was recently
in Cuba a few weeks ago,
and I'd like to ask you
a question concerning
the restoration of
the infrastructure,
specifically the buildings.
Do you think that
that is in the works?
Is the work being sped up?
How long do you foresee that
happening in the near future?
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: And since you
say that, I believe so.
I believe so that we
will be able to do that.
I've recently been studying a
lot of the monuments in Cuba,
and I've been working with
architects and archaeologists.
Recently, we've tried to locate
the remains of the old city
walls.
Unfortunately, those
remains are now
covered by parking
lots for buses
of all types, tourist buses.
And you know, at that
point, I said, break it all.
If you need to open
the streets, do so.
And I'm the kind of
person that's actually
been very lucky and fortunate,
because every time I crack open
the street, I find
something below.
We did find the remains
of the city wall,
and we're very happy
about that at this moment.
And with that same spirit, we
hope to pursue other projects.
You know, it's
very easy to build,
but it's very
difficult to restore.
And unfortunately, we haven't
been very lucky in the area,
in the economic arena.
You know, it's funny something
like UNESCO will grant me
a title of a count,
but they won't
allow us to receive
the money that we
need to do this to
make sure that we
can improve upon our national
heritage, which is our city.
It's easier to get blood than it
is to get money in some cases.
SPEAKER: Do we have
a question here?
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Thank you
so much for being here.
Thank you so very much
for your wisdom as well.
I'd like to put a rather
uncomfortable question to you,
if you will.
But there is a long history
of American companies
that have gone to
Cuba specifically
to exploit its riches.
What can you say at the
moment about the situation?
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Again, if you
ask me this question now,
and if I am put to the
alternative knowing
full well what's
being offered to us,
I think the most important
thing now is that now we
are stewards of our own future.
We are stewards of our own
sky and our own land in Cuba.
And it is up to
us now to decide.
Perhaps in the
past, it would have
been more difficult
to decide what to do,
what to do in this case.
What are our choices?
The alternative that is before
us now is an interesting one,
and again, I will say
this for a second time.
The word, romantic--
revolutions are not romantic.
But I would be hard
pressed to believe
that if I saw a revolution
that wasn't romantic,
I would probably be
very doubtful of it.
SPEAKER: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: What
do you believe is
one of the most important things
that Americans need to know
to change their view on Cuba?
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: The first thing
I'd like for you to know
is that Cuba is a friendly
and hospitable country.
We welcome any and
all to our country.
If there are athletes
present, and, of course,
their national anthem
is being played,
everyone stands in respect.
If you're walking down
the street as a tourist,
people greet you.
The most important thing is
that we have different views
and different ways of thinking.
And of course, there
are certain dogmas
that have been
imposed, particularly
in the realm of economics.
The United States is one of
the only countries in the world
that cannot visit Cuba openly.
Its citizens cannot
visit Cuba openly.
It is easier for you to visit
the democratic country of North
Korea than it is to visit Cuba.
We are tied by historical,
poetic, and artistic ties,
and that is what we
need to focus on.
And we need to make sure that we
vanquish any sort of separatism
on our part.
It is time to destroy
any kind of wall
that we may have
built in the past.
It is time to unite,
and it is time
to remember that we are
more together than we think.
SPEAKER: As a person who's been
to North Korea and to Cuba,
I can tell you it's easier
to get to North Korea.
So Professor is correct.
The good news is if you've
not been to Cuba before, it's
relatively easy to go under
one of 12 categories now,
and I would strongly
recommend that you visit.
Strong, strong recommendation
that you visit.
Yes, ma'am.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Thank you so
very much for being here.
I'm so happy about this new era
which is being born in Cuba.
I'd like to know
what you think is--
what is your dream for
Cuba at the moment,
particularly for the future?
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Every
single error, of course,
poses its own challenges.
And sometimes those challenges
are not prudent at the moment.
And of course, with the opening
of the relations between Cuba
and the United States,
there are many things that
still need to be worked out.
There are many
delicate issues that
still need to be talked about.
But I believe that we are
definitely on the right path.
My dream, my wish
for Cuba is that Cuba
will become more participatory,
that its population will
be more involved in its future,
that there will be more equity,
and that there will
be more prosperity.
Of course, the Cuba of
yesteryear, the Cuba from two,
three years ago will no
longer be in existence,
that people will be
able to have a life full
of dignity, that, of course,
the difference, the anguishing
difference that richness
versus poverty poses
will also allow people
to live a better life,
and ultimately, that there
is more justice for everyone.
That is the main goal,
and that is the thing
that I am dreaming for in Cuba.
SPEAKER: Yes, sir.
And I think we
have one following,
and these will be our
last two questions.
So yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Thank you
so very much for coming.
I wanted to mention that
one of the successes
of the Cuban revolution was
the push for literacy in Cuba.
And of course,
today, the internet
is a proponent of
this on a world scale.
What do you believe is
something that we at Google can
do to afford the
children of Cuba access
to information and content to
better allow them to get access
to a well-rounded education?
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: First
of all, I'd like
to answer your question
with the same excitement
and respect that you
garnered or warranted me.
The fact that Google
came to Havana
and showed its respect by
offering to help us with this
is something that is
of true importance,
because we have been
denied bandwidth in Cuba
for a very long time.
And as you mentioned,
it is imperative
that we do right
by our children.
In fact, the most
important thing
that we can do for
the Cuban children
is to provide them with
an equal education.
In fact, they are its
most important capital.
Aside from any
type of technology
that can be brought
to the island,
its citizens are
actually the ones
who are the stewards of
the country and the ones
that will help us in the future.
The idea of social
peace in the country
is something that we
have promoted also.
There are no
kidnappings in Cuba,
because if we were
to kidnap someone,
there would be no money to pay
for the kidnappers, of course.
So we would like to also
welcome Google again
to our coasts to
live out the life
that Marti had envisioned
through this virtual reality
that they so graciously
provided us with
and that they've created.
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Thank you so much,
Professor, for being here.
As a historian, what do you feel
is the impact of the internet
on society?
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Well, I'd
like to first point out
that my generation would bring
a cassette recorder to a party,
and we had to carry the
equipment among two people.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Well, I'll
start off with the word,
sensational, because it's
been a sensational revolution.
When I think about the
19th century in New York
and everything that happened
involving the telephone,
the radio, it is awe-inspiring
to think that you can look up
anything now on the internet .
Amazing is the word.
It's something that you can
look up on Google at any point.
In fact, I work very
closely with my assistant
to look up anything
that I need on Google.
As a historian, sometimes
I need to make sure
that I verify a
source, or perhaps I
have omitted some
type of factoid.
And it's amazing that today,
you can do all of this.
And we are at the threshold
of a new generation.
SPEAKER: When the history
of Cuba is written,
and the history of
Havana is written,
it will be history of Dr. Leal.
Foolishly with a
wheelbarrow, he set out
to preserve one of the
great things of humanity.
I admire him greatly,
and I encourage
you to spend as much time as
you can to study his work.
And it's a great honor to
welcome you here to Google.
EUSEBIO LEAL SPENGLER:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
INTERPRETER: Thank
you-- first of all, sir,
thank you so much for opening
your doors here at home to me.
And it's amazing, because
ever since we met,
I believe that our admiration
was always reciprocated.
It's been a great honor for
me to come here to visit you
in your very own headquarters.
And interestingly enough,
I've never really thought
about what sort of memory
will be held about me
or had about me in
posterity in the future.
I've always liked to walk
around old cemeteries
and read all of
the inscriptions.
We'll never forget you.
It's interesting, because
I've never really thought
about this, but as I
think about my own life,
I think that the
most important thing
is what I haven't
accomplished in life,
what has yet to be done.
And I've always said, I wish
I could live once again.
I could have one more life,
and I'd do it all over again.
I'd do exactly
what I did before.
And I would dedicate it
to the very same ideals.
And, of course, I
would choose to be
born in the same land, the very
same land in which I was born--
Cuba.
So thank you.
SPEAKER: Thank you all,
and thank you, Dr. Leal.
[APPLAUSE]